RYAN MATSUMOTO: From health
care to finance to social media,
data is helping businesses
innovate to a degree that
was once deemed unimaginable.
But at the same time, data
also presents new challenges
to the developers who are
trying to make it useful.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There are many different
factors to think
about when choosing a database,
especially when you're dealing
with large amounts of data.
Maybe you're building
a music application
that aims to recommend songs to
its users based on other music
that they like.
Initially, your app may
simply recommend the top songs
to users based on the genre
they listen to the most.
But what if you want to
take it a step further
and provide more personalized
song recommendations using
machine learning?
What if your app went viral?
These situations present new
challenges to your developers.
The scale of your
existing database
limits what you can do because
of the massive amount of data
required to power your music
personalization algorithm.
Where can you find a database
that scales easily, allows
for large numbers
of reads and writes
per second at low
latency, and comes
in a fully-managed service?
This is where Cloud Bigtable
table comes into play.
Bigtable is Google Cloud's
fully-managed, horizontally
scalable, NoSQL database
that is designed
to support large analytical
and operational workloads.
It's optimized for
applications that
require large numbers
of reads and writes
per second, low latency,
and performance at scale.
Let's take a look at several of
the key advantages of Bigtable.
First, Bigtable is
fast and performant.
It supports large
numbers of reads
and writes, with the
ability to support millions
of requests per second.
And it's able to do
so with low latency,
on the order of
single-digit milliseconds.
One potential
application for Bigtable
could be collecting
global air quality data
from thousands of sensors.
Bigtable can handle the massive
write throughput generated
and also be able to read that
data quickly and reliably.
Bigtable is also a
highly scalable database.
Throughput can be
adjusted dynamically
by adding or removing
Bigtable nodes.
A node is just a set
of compute resources
that provides up to 10,000
additional queries per second
and is attached to
additional storage capacity.
There's no downtime when you
change the number of nodes,
so you can seamlessly
scale up to meet
the demands of a
large batch workload
and scale back down
once it's complete.
Thanks to the
scalability, Bigtable
allows you to store up
to petabytes of data.
This can be helpful if your
application is growing rapidly
and you need to scale quickly to
meet the demands of new users.
Bigtable is also a fully-managed
and reliable database.
This allows you to concentrate
on building your application,
rather than spending a lot of
time fine-tuning the database.
Data replication across
multiple Google data centers
ensures high availability
and low latency for users
all around the world.
In fact, Bigtable recently
joined Cloud Firestore
and Cloud Spanner with up
to 99.999% availability SLA.
You can replicate your data
by creating new clusters.
A cluster is a Bigtable
service in a specific location.
Bigtable is
eventually consistent.
So when you write a
change to one cluster,
you will eventually
be able to read
that change from other clusters,
but only after the change
is replicated.
Bigtable also handles
backups, so you can easily
recover from application-level
data corruption, as well
as human errors.
Bigtable integrates easily
with popular big data tools,
making it easy for development
teams to get started.
It has support for the
open-source HBase API standard,
making it easy to integrate
with the Apache ecosystem,
including HBase, Beam,
Hadoop, and Spark.
Bigtable also integrates
well with other Google Cloud
big data products, like
BigQuery, Dataflow,
and Dataproc.
While Cloud Bigtable makes
sense for many use cases,
there are situations where
a different Google Cloud
database may make more sense.
Spanner is preferable if
you need strong consistency
globally, which makes it
better for transactions.
It's also a SQL
database, which is better
for more structured data.
BigQuery is an
enterprise data warehouse
optimized for gaining
organizational insights
from large amounts of
relational structured data.
Bigtable, on the
other hand, is better
for applications that
need high numbers of reads
and writes for second.
Cloud Firestore is Google
Cloud's serverless, NoSQL,
document-based
database that makes
it particularly easy to
integrate with mobile and web
apps.
It's a good choice if
you need a flexible data
model with a guarantee
of strong consistency.
Let's learn more about
Bigtable's data model.
Bigtable stores data in
massively scalable tables
that can scale up to billions of
rows and thousands of columns.
As a NoSQL database, Bigtable
stores data in key-value pairs
stored in rows and columns.
Each row represents
a single entity,
while each column contains
values for each row.
Columns that are
related to each other
can be grouped into
column families
for organizational purposes.
At the intersection of each
row and column combination,
you can have multiple cells,
with each cell representing
a different version of the
data at a given timestamp.
This makes Bigtable great
for time series analysis.
Bigtable tables
are sparse, meaning
that if a column is not
filled in for a given row,
it doesn't take up any space.
If you're looking for a highly
scalable, reliable, and fast
database to handle
big data workloads,
Bigtable may be just
what your business needs.
Try it out for yourself by going
to cloud.google.com/bigtable,
and stay tuned to hear
more about Bigtable.